foreign welcome back to CBS mornings
there is new controversy over the
saudi-funded live golf series and this
time it involves former president Donald
Trump and 9 11 families the latest event
tees off today at one of Trump's golf
clubs at Bedminster in New Jersey the
former president was seen playing a
practice round yesterday with Dustin
Johnson and Bryson dechambeau 9 11
families are angry that Saudi Arabia
country linked to the 2001 Terror
attacks is backing the golf league Nikki
Batista's following the story for us and
joins us at the table Nikki good morning
Vlad good morning former president
Donald Trump is expected to be at the
tournament this weekend 9 11 families
are accusing Saudi Arabia of sports
washing its human rights violations and
called the tournament a grotesque
prioritization of Saudi money
my two brothers were murdered on 9 11.
outrage 911 families released an ad
earlier this week taking aim at the live
golf tournament this golf tournament is
taking place 50 miles from Ground Zero
it's the controversial live golf league
is funded by Saudi Arabia's public
investment fund it's part of a
multi-billion dollar effort by the
kingdom to prepare its reputation after
a long history of human rights
violations they haven't been held
accountable for any of these crimes and
we're supposed to just be like yeah
nothing to see here where's my golf ball
let's go tee off when you first learned
that Bedminster would host a live golf
tournament what was your reaction
shock
anger beyond comprehension
and just sick Dennis McGinley is part of
the group 911 Justice his brother Danny
died at the World Trade Center I'm Not
Angry Anymore and beyond that it's I'm
more sad and I'm heartbroken that
like whatever happened to truth and
Justice is that replaced by oil and
money in 2016 then president Trump also
appeared to point to Saudi Arabia as the
driving force behind 9 11. who blew up
the world Trade Center it wasn't the
Iraqis it was sorting have you take a
look at Saudi Arabia on Thursday Trump
appeared to take a different tone in an
interview with ESPN well nobody's gotten
to the bottom of 9 11 unfortunately and
they should have as to The Maniacs that
did that horrible thing to our city to
our country to the world last year an
FBI FB abort showed evidence that
that provided support to at least two of
the 911 terrorists 15 of the 19911
hijackers or Saudi Nationals Saudi
Arabia says it had nothing to do with
the terror attacks live golf which
launched earlier this summer has been
controversial since its Inception in
June the PGA Tour suspended 17 players
who opted to play and Liv's inaugural
event those players included top names
like Phil Mickelson and Dustin Johnson
whose reported contracts with live are
upwards of 100 million dollars a piece
when asked for confirmation Liv told CBS
News we do not comment on confidential
contracts earlier this week pro golfer
Paul Casey defended the league I can
honestly look you in the eye and say
that I see a trajectory a positive
trajectory in the kingdom and it was a
really good experience that I've had
when I've been there and I hope that
continues but from McGinley the
saudi-back league is devastating he is
calling on the athlete to stand with 9
11 victims if you don't want to stand
with us the families
stand with the people that how to make a
decision in those buildings should I
jump from the 100th Floor should I burn
alive
or the people in the airplanes that had
a call their loved ones and give their
final goodbye
do it for them
in a statement to CBS News Liv Gulf said
as we have said all along these families
have our deepest sympathy while some may
not agree we believe golf is a Force for
good around the world at the end of
October Trump is expected to host live
golf for another tournament at Trump
National Doral Miami CBS News reached
out to Trump for comment on the
controversy and did not hear back and as
Dennis said in the piece he and other
victims families just want
accountability yeah it's got to be
incredibly disappointing distressing for
them to hear former president of the
United States say we haven't gotten to
the bottom of 9 11 when in fact the
United States President Barack Obama
took out Osama Bin Laden the man
responsible for 9 11. and in his own
words he's said something completely
different which is a contradiction on
the day of yeah you can understand the
pain and the anger of those families I
thought Dennis put it very well if you
don't want to do it for this then think
about the people that had to make that
decision I think about that a lot when I
look at those images do you burn here or
do you jump what do you do yeah such a
terrible terrible day and I don't know
how you just that term Sports washing is
new to me I haven't heard that before I
don't know how you just disregard all of
that for any amount of money yes and we
have to remember all of the victims and
Danny Dennis's brother had five children
the youngest was a newborn the 10 year
old was the oldest when he passed and we
have to think about them too yes living
seeing this this is uh money over
morality and golf is hanging in the
balance thank you very much